PROFESSOR: So
we're going to talk
about state machines,
which is a topic
that you're going to see
in many further courses,
because state machines model
step by step processes.
And of course, if you think
about a computation, normally
the way you think about it is
that it's doing instructions,
step by step, one after
another, until it finally
reaches termination.
Likewise, various
digital circuits
move through stages
or states until they
produce a final answer.
So state machines come up in
at least those circumstances
and in many others.
And the general model
of state machine
involves the idea that
you can give it input
and it responds to them,
but we don't really
need that for our purposes.
So let's look at our
example of a state machine.
Here's maybe a
particular simple one.
This is a description of a
state machine that counts to 99.
So the circles are indicating
what its states are, and we've
named them from 0 through 99.
And then there's a final
state called overflow,
and that funny arc
is an indication
that if you're in
overflow mode and you
make another step by
following the arc,
you get back to overflow mode.
But if you're in 0, you
can make a step to 1.
And if you're in 1, you can
make a step to 2, and so on.
So starting off at the start
state, which is generally
indicated by that double mark.
So to indicate where to start.
Then the description
of this machine,
consistent in complete
description is a set of states
which are pictured as 0
through 99 plus overflow,
a set of transitions
which are indicated
by the arrows, which
is how one state can
move to another state.
And the transitions
can be summarised
by saying that there
of the form of i
to i plus 1 for i
between 0 and 99.
And then there's a 99
transition to overflow,
and once you're in overflow,
you stay in overflow.
So the picture at the top is
saying exactly the same thing
as we've said here in
mathematical notation,
explicitly describing
what the transitions are.
So this is a machine that if
you really build something
to behave this way, it
wouldn't be much use,
because once it's
overflowed, it's dead,
because it stays there.
Real machine to be useful would
have a reset transition, which
took overflow back to zero.
But this illustrates
the basic idea.
So let's look at a fun
example from a Die Hard movie.
I've forgotten which one it was.
But there was one with Bruce
Willis and Samuel Jackson
playing a detective
and a friend that he
meets who helps him
deal with a bad man,
as is the case in
all these movies.
This time, the bad
man's name is Simon.
And what Simon says
to them as they
stand behind the fountain
in the park shown
on the previous slide is
that on the foundation,
there should be two
jugs, do you see them?
A five gallon and
a three gallon.
Fill one of these jugs with
exactly four gallons of water
and place it on the scale,
and the timer will stop.
The timer and the scale are
not shown in that picture,
but there's a scale
and a timer nearby.
You must be precise,
one ounce more or less
will result in detonation.
If you're still alive in
five minutes, we'll speak.
OK.
So let's think about formalizing
this as a state machine
to see what's going on.
So but first of all, to
understand the specification
informally.
What there is a three gallon
jug and a five gallon jug
that's capable of holding
water, and an unlimited supply
of water that you can
get from the fountain.
And the basic moves
that you can make--
So with this set up, the kind
of moves that you can make
would be, say you fill up the
three gallon jug with water,
and then you could pour
the three gallon jug
into the five gallon jugs.
And the three
gallon jug was empty
and the five gallon jug you
knew had exactly three gallons
in it.
And then you can do other things
like empty a jug and fill a jug
and empty them into each other.
So let's model this
as a state machine.
And the first decision
we need to make
is what's the state going to be.
Well, the state-- the
obvious model for the state
is the amount of water
in each of the jugs.
So b is the amount
in the big jug
and l is the amount
the little jug.
And what we know
about b and l is
that they're going to be some
amount between 0 and 5 for b,
and 0 and 3 for l.
We're going to quickly
realize that we
need them to be
integers, but off hand we
can allow them to
be real numbers.
Because after all,
you could just
pour some arbitrary
amount of water
into the big jug,
any amount that it'll
hold between 0 and 5.
Although, that'll be
dangerous, because as soon as
you do that, you're going
to lose track of exactly how
much is in there and
you won't know when
you have four gallons or not.
So let's formalize the possible
moves that we can have.
So first of all, the
start state is 0,0,
because we start
with both jugs empty.
And then what are the
possible transitions
of how b and l moves?
Well, let's see.
The fill the little
jug move amounts
to saying that if you
have an amount of b in big
and l in little, then you
can make a transition called
fill the little jug into b,
and big is still unchanged,
and 3 in little
for l less than 3.
I'm going to forbid
the vacuous move where
the little jug is already
full and you try to fill it.
That doesn't count, so
l has to be less than 3,
you can make it 3 by
filling the little jug.
Similarly, you could fill the
big jug if b is less than 5.
Then you can turn it
into 5 by filling it.
And then you can empty the
little jug, which is easy.
If you go from b,
l you go to b, 0.
And likewise, you can
empty the big jug.
Those are the easy moves.
A slightly more complicated
move is pour the big jug
into the little jug.
Well if there's no
overflow, what that means
is that there's l in the little
jug and b in the big job.
And after you've poured the
big jug into the little jug,
there's b plus l
in the little one,
and nothing in the big one.
But let's be careful
here about what exactly--
we're doing math, we're
not sort of-- we're
trying to get away
from the metaphor.
So what is no overflow means?
It simply means that
b plus l will fit.
b plus l is less
than or equal to 3.
All right.
What's the other case
of pouring the big jug
into the little jug?
Well that's when b plus l
won't fit, in which case,
you pour into the little jug.
It's got l, so you pour in
3 minus l to fill it up.
And then what's left in b is
b minus the 3 minus little l
that you poured.
So that the other wise case,
when there is overflow.
And similarly, there are moves
for pouring the little jug
into the big jug.
So that then is a
formal specification
of the Die Hard
machine and the moves
that we're going to allow.
Now, you could allow
other moves like randomly
pouring out a little
water, or randomly filling
up a little water.
But if you did that,
again, you lose
track of how much
water is in the jug.
So these are the
only safe moves.
And they're the only ones
we're going to model.
All right.
So let's go back to
Simon's challenge.
He wants to disarm the bomb
by getting exactly four
gallons of water in the jug
and measure it on the scale,
or things will blow up.
And how do you do it?
Well, why don't
you take a moment
to think about it
before I proceed
to the next set of slides or
before you let me proceed.
But just to understand
the rules again,
watch the work here's how.
We're going to start off
with both jugs empty.
So we start off in state
0,0, and the first move
is going to be to fill
the big jug, which
takes us to state 5, 0.
Where the big jug has 5 and
the little jug is still empty.
Then we're going to pour
from the big into the little.
So now, the little jug has 3.
We're filling up the little one.
That leaves two in the big jug.
Now we're going to
empty the little one,
we still have 2
left in the big one.
And now we're going to
pour from the big one
into the little one, so the
little one has 2 gallons
and the big one is empty.
Now, we fill the big
jug, and there's still
2 gallons in the little one
and 5 gallons of the big one.
Now we pour off from the five
gallon jug until the one gallon
jug is full, that's removing the
1 gallon that the 3 gallon jug
still has capacity for.
We reduced to full 2
gallons in the little jug,
and four gallons, our
target in the big jug.
So we've accomplished it.
And we're done.
So the bomb doesn't go off.
All right.
So the point of this
exercise is really just
to practice how the moves
work and what the states are,
but the questions
I want to raise
is suppose that we want
to have a Die Hard once
and for all scenario,
in which we're
tired of the remakes
of these movies.
And we proposed that
in the next movie,
that Simon, if
he's still around,
offers an alternative
challenge, where
instead of a three gallon
and a five gallon jug,
there's a three gallon
jug and a nine gallon jug.
And now the question is,
can you get four gallons
into the big jug by pouring
back and forth with rules
like these, or can't you?
And can you prove it?
Well my guess is
that you probably
can figure out what's going
on, because what's happening
is if you start off with
nothing in either jug,
and you do these moves
of filling up a jug
and pouring one
jug into another,
you'll discover that the
amount of water in any jug
is always divisible by 3.
This is a preserved invariant.
Any state that you can get
to, starting off from 0,0,
3 will divide the number
of gallons in each jug.
We could state it this way.
There's a property of
states, property of b and l,
which is the state,
which is that 3 divides
b-- that vertical
line is a shorthand
for the symbol divides.
So three divides b, or
b is a multiple of 3.
3 divides l.
Synonym, l is a multiple of 3.
And the claim is that that's
always going to be true.
So in case that's
not obvious, you
might not have all the
rules in your head.
Let's just take a look at one
of the more complicated rules.
This was the rule
where you're pouring
the big jug into
the little jug up
until the little jug is full.
And that transition is
that if you're in state b,
l, you move to b minus
3 minus l, and 3.
And if you look at this now,
clearly if 3 divides both b
and l, both components
of the state
you're at, then
in the new state,
well 3 obviously
divides the contents
of the little jug, which is 3.
But three also
divides the contents
of the big jug, which is
a multiple of 3, namely b
minus 3, which is a
multiple of 3 minus w,
which is a multiple of 3.
When you take a linear
combination of multiples of 3,
you get a multiple of 3.
And you look at all
the other transitions,
and they check equally well.
If you're in a
state b, l, and you
move to a new state b prime,
l prime, if 3 divides b and l,
then 3 divides b
prime and l prime.
So this is what's called
a preserved invariant.
And of course the corollary
is that in the Die Hard once
and for all game with the
3 gallon jug and the 9
gallon jug, you can't get to
any state of the form 4, x,
because 4 is not divisible
by 3, and therefore Bruce
is going to die.
Now what we've illustrated
here is an argument
that's known as Floyd's
Invariant Principle,
and it's really nothing
but induction reformulated
for state machines.
The statement of what
is invariant principle
is that we're going to
define a preserved invariant
as a property of states.
And a preserved
invariants means it
has the property that if you're
in a state that has property p,
and it's possible to make a
single transition to state r,
then r will also
have property p.
This is just like
the induction step.
We have to prove that p
n implies p of n plus 1.
So if you have a
preserved invariant,
then if the property
holds at the start state,
then it's obvious
that the property
will hold for all of the states
that you can possibly get to.
That p of r will hold
for all reachable states.
And you can prove
this by induction
on the number of
states, but I think
it's clear that if you have a
property that you begin with,
and it doesn't
change making a step,
it's never going to change.
And that's all that Floyd's
invariant principle states.
So in particular,
since the property p
holds in all reachable
states, if there
is any final state which
the machine reaches,
then p is going to
hold in that state.
And what we saw was-- we're
using the word preserved
invariant to distinguish
the definition here
from another usage
that's co-opted the word
invariant to mean a property
that's true in all states.
And while it's nice to
know that some property is
true in all states,
the way you prove
that is by having a
preserved invariance.
You want to distinguish the two.
Technically if you look
at this, the predicate
that's always false is
a preserved invariant.
Because of the condition,
as usual the way implication
works.
If the antecedent is false, then
the entire implication is true.
So if you're always false,
then it's always the case
that if false held in a state,
which it never does, then
it has to hold in any
state you can get to,
so that implication is true.
So just remember that preserved
invariants that are constantly
false exist, they are good
preserved in variance.
But they're not what other
people would call an invariant.
We use preserved invariance
to prove that a property is
true in all states.
It's a methodology.
So let's do one more
example to wrap this up.
Suppose I have a robot on
a grid, the integer grid,
and we can think then
of the coordinates
of the integer as a pair of--
the coordinates of the robot
as the coordinates of
the square that it's in,
a pair of non-negative integers.
Now the way that
this robot can move
is we can make a diagonal
move in one step.
So it could move one step to
the northeast or southeast
or northwest or
southwest and that's it.
And the question
I want to ask is,
suppose you start the robot
off at the origin, at 0,0.
Is there some way that
it can wander around,
following its moves,
and get to a next state
where it's moved 1 square over?
That is, it gets
to the square 0,1.
The answer to that is settled
again by a preserved invariant.
I don't know whether
it's obvious to you yet,
but it will be in a moment.
I'm claiming you can't
get to the square 0,1,
and the reason is that there's
are preserved invariant
of that set of
robot moves, namely
the sum of the coordinates
is even is an invariant.
If the sum of the coordinates
is even, it stays even.
And why is that?
Well, any move adds
plus or minus 1
to the coordinates
of both x and y.
Maybe x and y both
go up by 1, in which
case, the sum of x
and y increases by 2.
So if it was even,
it stays even,
or they both go down by
1, or maybe one goes up
and the other goes down,
in which case, the sum
doesn't change in every case.
If x plus y was
even, it stays even.
As a matter of fact, if
it was odd, it stays odd.
Moves actually preserve
the parity of x plus y.
But the invariant is
that x plus y is even.
Now, what else is the case.
Well 0,0-- 0 plus 0
is 0, which is even.
And so we're in Floyd
invariant principal case,
where all the positions you
can get to from the origin 0,0,
which has an even sum,
have to have an even sum.
And since 1 plus 0 is odd, you
can't get to that square, 1,0.
It's not reachable.
So the parity invariant of
the diagonally moving robot
will set us up for an analysis
of the 15 puzzle game.
That's this logo that we've
had on every slide in 6042
so far with 6 blank,
4, 2, on the diagonal.
This is a game where there
are these little numbered
tiles that slide into
the blank square,
and the question
is how to permute--
how to get from one permutations
of the numbers to another.
It turns out that the
analysis of that game
depends on a parity
invariant reminiscent
of a slightly more sophisticated
than the diagonally
moving robot.
Let's look at one more
example of using the invariant
to verify a little algorithm
that actually will be quite
important as the
course progresses,
and that is fast exponentiation.
So in this set up,
a is a real number
and b is a non-negative integer.
I want to compute
the b power of a.
Let's say b was 128, and I
want to compute the 128th power
of some real number a.
Well, I can multiply a by itself
127 times, that would work
fine.
But you think about it, suppose
I square a and then I square it
again, and I square it again,
then in about eight squarings,
instead of 99
multiplications, I'm
going to get to 8 of the 128th.
Now if b is not a power of
two, you adjust it slightly,
and using that idea, you can
compute the bth power of a much
more rapidly than
if you just naively
multiplied out b minus 1 times.
So let's look at the
pseudocode for this algorithm.
Here, XYZ in our temporary
registers y and z, hold-- y, z,
and r all hold integers.
And x holds this real number a.
And you can read
the code if you wish
but in fact, I'm going
to immediately jump
to the slightly more
abstract and easier
to understand version of
it as a state machine.
So what matters about this
fast exponentiation algorithm
as a state machine
is that first of all,
there are three states
to real numbers,
and a non-negative integer.
And the start state is going
to be that the number a is
in the first register,
or in the first location,
first coordinate of the states.
1 is the real number in
the second coordinate,
and b the target exponent,
is the non-negative integer
in the third component.
The transitions are
going to be as follows.
Here's a simple one.
If I have an amount x
in the first location, y
in the second location, z in
the third, then if z is positive
and even, then I'm going
to square x, leave y
alone, and divide z by 2.
And that's the new
state that I get.
On the other hand, if
z is odd and positive,
then I'm going to square
x, multiply y by x,
and again take the quotient
of z, divide z by 2.
OK.
Why does this state machine
do fast exponentiation,
why is it correct?
And the insight is that
there's a preserved invariant
of this machine.
And the preserved invariant
is that y times x to the z
is always a to the b.
SO let's see how to verify
that, that yx to the z
is equal to a to the b.
Let's just look at maybe the
slightly more interesting
of the two transition
rules, which
is when z is positive
and odd, the xyz state
moves to a new state,
indicated in green.
Where the new value of x is
x squared, the new value of y
is xy, and the new value
of z is z minus 1 over 2.
Remember, you went to the
quotient of z divided by 2,
and when z is odd, that means
z minus-- it's literally
z minus 1 over 2.
Well, do the new values
satisfy the invariant
if I plug-in the green values
of x squared for y and xy
for x-- I'm sorry, x
squared for x, xy for y,
and z minus 1 over 2 for z?
Well let's see what happens.
If I take the new value
of y, which is xy,
and I multiply it by the new
value of x, which is x squared,
raised to the new value of
z, which is z minus 1 over 2.
Let's do a little algebraic
simplification of that.
Well, the x squared to
the z minus 1 over 2
becomes x to the z minus 1.
And I'm just
carrying over the xy.
And then that simplifies
to simply y times x times x
to the z minus 1, or yz
to the z, which we assumed
was equal to a to the b, so sure
enough, the new values of x, y,
and z satisfy the invariant.
It's a preserved invariant,
and an even simpler argument
applies to the other transition,
when z is positive and even.
So we verified that this
is a preserved invariant.
Now at the start, remember, we
start off with the real number
a in register x, the real number
b in z, and the real number
1 in y, which is
the accumulator.
And 1 times a to b
is equal to a to b.
So this is a-- this
preserved invariant
is true of the start state.
That means by Floyd's
Invariant Principle,
that it is true at
this the final state,
if and when the thing stops.
Well, when does
this machine stop?
As long as z is positive,
it can keep moving.
So it gets stuck when z is 0?
What happens if it
ever gets to z is 0?
If it gets stuck, then the
invariant says that yx to the 0
has to equal a to the b.
But of course, yx to
the 0 is nothing but y.
And what we conclude
is, that sure enough,
this machine leaves the
desired exponential value
in the register y, which
is where we get the answer.
And that's why this
algorithm is correct.
Now another aspect of
what's going on here
is proving that the
algorithm does terminate.
So let me just say a word
that Floyd distinguished
sort of these two aspects
of program correctness
that typically come up.
One is showing that if you
get an answer, it's correct,
and that's what we just did.
If this machine stops, if
it ever gets to the case
where z is 0, then y
has the right answer.
But we haven't
proved that it stops.
So we've shown
that it's partially
correct like a partial function.
It might not be
defined everywhere,
we haven't shown that yet,
but when it is defined,
if gives the right answer.
The other aspect of
correctness is termination,
showing in effect, that
the function is total,
that the program
always does stop.
Well in this case,
there's an easy way
to see why it always stops.
Because at every transition,
z is being halved or more.
z is a non-negative
integer valued variable.
And since we're
halving it, or making
it even smaller than
half of it at every step,
it means that since it
starts with the value z,
it can't get smaller, more than
log to the base 2 of b times,
because by then, it
would have hit 0.
And so we can be sure
that this machine
makes it most log to the
base 2 of b transitions.
And then it has to get
stuck at the only place it
can get stuck, which
is when z equals 0.
And there is a picture of my
friend, an early colleague,
Bob Floyd, whom I met at the
very beginning of my career
at Carnegie Mellon University.
We worked together
for about one year
before he went off to Stanford.
And you can read much
more about his life
in a warm and detailed
eulogy written
by his best friend, Don Knuth.
Floyd won the Turing Award
for his major contributions,
both to program correctness
and to programming language
parsing.